foreign
I can't believe that kid that was
harming themselves would end up sitting
here I've come so far
for the first time I'm seeing that
there's an abundance of opportunity
I wish I wouldn't have blamed myself so
much for the way I felt and for the
self-harm because that's made it harder
I actually needed to do was be brave
enough to step out of myself
self-harm behaviors are warning signs
that something is not right
there's great optimism for people making
a recovery that's good and that lasts
I first sort of started self-harm when I
was about 16.
it was a lack of confidence and sort of
feeling like I didn't fit in anywhere
and I just had all this frustration
about my identity who I was
my mum was just worried about me
constantly I was not really talking to
anyone about it just assuming this was
normal and everyone felt like that I
experienced self-harm related to my
anger especially
from a young age I kind of learned that
the anger was a scary thing or a thing
that I shouldn't allow myself to feel I
experienced trauma that I blacked out
that I couldn't access for years I
didn't really know what I was doing I
have a plan or purpose even but I was
getting desperate
[Music]
self-harm is a behavior and it's a form
of communication self-harm expresses
emotional pain through a transformation
into physical pain there are a few
statistics in relation to self-harm one
in six children and young people aged 16
years in England had a probable mental
illness in 2021 would translate to
something like five children in every
classroom of 30.
if you can sell Farm in multiple ways it
doesn't always have to be through the
standard ways that we know self-harming
relationships substance misuse so
there's a variety of different ways in
which people do it I self-harmed on and
off with cutting then I develop anything
disorder I just became very secretive
and then it sort of turned into more
neglecting myself
I'd been out drinking and I just didn't
stop I noticed that a lot of my anger
was directed at myself whether it was
like pinching myself or bites on the
inside of my cheek things like that a
lot of my binging would happen when I
was angry or upset and didn't feel like
I was being listened to in a very
traditional gender-based ways often
males will tend to self-harm in quite
violent ways so getting into a fight
sometimes they put their fist through a
glass we're learning a lot more about
the experience of trauma there's a kind
of capital T trauma but there's also
small tea drama all those small wounds
that we all have from adverse life
experiences where perhaps we felt we
haven't been seen or known so it's not
that something happens or maybe
something didn't happen
people know that it's hard being a
teenager
it just wasn't that
my parents wanted to help but they
didn't know how so I hit it better
I didn't want to ask for help because I
didn't want to seem like I was attention
seeking or belittled or made fun of you
want to be seen but you don't want
attention for for the self-harm when
people say that self-harm is attention
seeking is to see it as attention
needing because self-harm is a form of
communication in order to move forward
you need to find an alternative form of
communication convert it into any other
outward form of communication rather
than making it implode making the pain
implode back on you well something I'm
doing to work towards living a better
life is therapy I still withhold a lot
of myself from other people but I
definitely get to talk to myself through
the art that I do my anger is a wave
that can come and go being angry doesn't
make me an angry person I got a journal
out and just started writing I tend to
share a lot of my poetry or anything
I've written with my mom
through running my Instagram account and
working in the mental health industry I
think it's shown how much helping other
people has helped myself walking is a
great tool for me walking allows me to
process things in my mind I do lots of
different things I've had to plan my my
life in a way that I that I feel good
and I don't relapse and it's important
to get your feelings out in whatever way
creative projects are really good in
order to learn how to verbalize things
and understand what's going on
coming together with a group of people
that were like myself sharing words and
experiences feels really comforting
expressing myself in a creative way
using my own words I never thought would
be possible for someone like me
one thing I've learned over the last
year or so is that it just takes a few
moments of Bravery to get the support
that you need you don't need to feel
that you deserve it you just need to
know you need it it's not always going
to be perfect but just do your best
no matter what you do
people are there to support you
we definitely need to be open for people
to
tell us what they need Society just
needs to be a lot more person-centered
and trauma-informed being trauma aware
we have a responsibility with our young
people to relate to them where they are
having some compassion that somebody may
have experienced some trauma is helpful
it's really important to see this as a
period of time in your life which you
marked as being distressing
and to be able to see that as a phase
that you have now moved from and to be
proud of having got through it you can
do it
I thought that was it whatever I was
feeling wherever I was then was going to
be forever and it wasn't
it hasn't been easy every step of the
way growing up or as an adult but it is
not the same but things change and they
get better
and
come and go
oh
[Music]
foreign
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
Subscribe button and click the Bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video